but this question comes from david he
says
uh with schools wanting to go back
isolated
house does this affect children's mental
health
oh this is big that's a big so um
schools are
right now are in a no-win situation and
i'm calling it a no-win and no blame
it just is and so kind of cutting
through all the silliness
there is no question kids they call it
the nerd word as they co-regulate
kids do not have the ability to stand on
their own two feet
with identity with am i safe am i loved
they are always ping-ponging off the
people in their
in their world okay that's why having
parents who look their kids in the eye
and talk to them and read to them
and walk with them and listen to them is
so important because kids are getting
feedback from the environment
this is going to be tough for kids this
is really going to be tough
going back and figuring out how to talk
to a teacher with a mask on is going to
be hard
um i don't know a way around that
because kids are also
carriers of kova depending on where you
listen what what news source you listen
to and what doctors you listen to
it's just going to be hard so i think
schools are going to have to be hyper
intentional
about listening about eye contact about
journaling about talking through things
with their kids
and they're going to have to be hyper
intentional about helping parents have
tools to process the school day when
they go home
well that's a good point and here's the
thing you can't pass on what you don't
possess
that's right and so as a parent i think
it's also important to realize
hey how have you been approaching this
covet situation you know
how have you been talking about it
outwardly and i think it's important
john to also have
age appropriate conversations with these
young people
absolutely pretending it doesn't exist
yeah it creates attention in your home
and kids are
the best about feeling tension and
looking in the mirror and saying it must
be my fault
because they co-regulate themselves
they're always looking so if they feel
distance from a parent
the kid says it's my fault what do i
what did i do to screw this up what did
i do to make my parent i want to talk to
me or make my friends or my teacher
and so it's always communicating in the
in the most age-appropriate but
intentional way with kids
that this is a messy situation we love
you we love you we love you and show it
show it show it show it that's good